en fait les chirurgies vous est demandé
aujourd'hui pour les téléspectateurs
d'avouer quelque chose que vous faites
et que vous alors julien jeu c'est votre
truc cool donc si vous ne la voulez pas
je vais le dire nos matches et je vais
le dire c'est quoi je suis père j'étais
à un via une cour qui est pas très loin
d'ici
déjà des données 2 donc je vais vers le
deuxième a bondi le premier une cour où
on prend un peu l'air certains fument et
puis j'étais allé vous donnez un coup de
fil à la cour on m'a dit antennes dans
une minute et à ce moment là je ma
personne j'ai très envie de faire pipi
ce jour là il y avait deux voitures
garées nos canards de à qui ça va pas
faire plaisir il y avait un 4 4 une
super voiture de sport et je me suis dit
comme étaient entre les deux voitures
j'ai finalement n'ont pas choisi le 4 4
et la voiture de sport et j'ai fais pipi
sur la portière de la voiture de sport
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'hésitais entre 4,4 et rugby est ce que
tu as qui est bien et il a il a pissé
sur votre voiture
non mais c'est pas là moi j'ai fait du
vent dans le fond vestiaires si vous
avez un truc à vous et valérie alors ce
que je fait qu'il ne faut pas faire part
c'est que je laisse tout allumée chez
moi tout le temps qui passe et sa valise
un vocable bah oui
[Rires]
le fait pas il faut pas le faire chier
mais ne le fait pas c'est pas chez vous
même
non mais oh
j'aime ma boîte eric est toujours rempli
le prospectus sont toujours en semant
opus avec la compagne électorale et du
coup en fonction de l'humeur kojak mes
voisins chez des voisins
les relations compliquées voisins ce que
j'ai un chien et deux gars qui quand je
suis pas là il aboie tout le temps
excusez moi hélas vrai que c'est
l'interview dans 30 minutes
et du coup j'ai souvent des voisins qui
se peignent est donc en fonction de ce
qui est qu'ils se plaignent le plus je
prends tout mais ce prospectus est tout
ce que je trouvais je bourre leur boîte
aux lettres jusqu'à cela déborde arabe
en israël même vélo voilà ce que vous
pourriez mais pas les boîtes aux lettres
alors là vous allez voir maxime ghanim a
avoué un jour j'étais chez moi nous il
est très bien manger en fait les août
périmés
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'habitude de prendre le métro et
le train à la recherche des scoops et
des informations il avoué c'est que je
porte souvent des écouteurs je fais
croire que j'écoute de la musique
sauf que j'écoutais absolument pas la
musique je ne mets absolument rien et
j'écoute toutes les conversations
géraldine manier un jour j'ai lu le
livre de 22 pages monsieur était de 19,2
on n'est pas si loin
non oui au début quand j'étais écrivain
j'ai écrit à peu près mais trois quatre
premiers romans déjà ça c'est levage
déjà normalement bon là on l'est on
l'entend pas cette phrase nous
normalement
moi j'étais écrivain j'avais écrit mais
trois quatre premiers romans vas-y ouais
je faisais le tour des librairies
ouais on voir si mon livre a été vendu
ouais et souvent ils se retrouvaient
sous les tables ou dans les étagères
perdu est donc le premier et je les
mettais devant way ou le rebelle
salut c'est moi bah ouais c'était un peu
long tour j'avais adressé pour fait que
les libraires
et depuis combien vous et vous aviez
fait pipi dans la bouteille de quelqu'un
oui ça c'est des affaires s'est toujours
en rapport avec le baby est arrivé donc
c'est en fait uriner log 1 je suis
heureux dans cette équipe
j'aime bien sortir pendant les pauses
prendre l'air et j'aime bien c'est vrai
faire pipi dehors et je faisais arriver
on pique contre les poubelles c'est
vraiment un truc de mec de tf1
je crois que ça apparemment le mot s'est
passé entre taux longs que ceux des
pépites d'or il ya une note qui a été
fait
l'attention des directions des ce2 au
pour comble répercute d'arrêter de piste
dans la cour
donc j'ai arrêté de piste dans la cour
pardon c'est vous qui puissiez dans la
cour oui mais un jour il a pissé sur un
mec épicé sur sa voiture
alors qu en fait j'adore aller à la
plage quoi j'ai ma petite serviette
bleue ma grande serviette et l'été je
vais à la plage
alors moi j'ai mon petit transistor des
années 90 à piles il est tout gris mat
bien qu'une petite embellie de demander
et donc du coup j'arrive à la plage we
had métaux isabelle est à la place était
allongé à la plage annonce toi la
plainte doit l'annoncer à la place je
meurs tu vois la plagne annoncera la
plaque je mets ma petite serviette à
côté d'elle et mon petit transistor et
en juillet j'adore le tour de france
donc je mets ma petite radio à fond
j'écoute le tour de france et quand les
français gagnent donc elle me connaît
pas les à la page gmail comme ça à côté
de la fille à côté de moi alors moi il
ya un truc c'est au restaurant pour
faire rire mes camarades alors ça at
elle ajouté
je me sens pas nous c'est très simple
j'adore me mène plein de petits
gourmands entre les dents et puis je
vais vous ça vous avez recruté déteste
quand il vraiment mouche les oreilles
miné tout petit tampon dans les oreilles
non mais au rythme des sons blanche mais
des concours de miaulements delà des
contraintes de la connaître les faits
soient nos meilleurs éléments avec ses
charges combien savent que c'est un
concours ils s'inscrivent à bamako comme
m
un résultat que le ca dépasse à peine
les amours ça va
[Musique]
[Rires]
ces cas là où le grand prix de formule 1
de monaco
[Applaudissements]